und er bewegt sich doch Deutschland
liefert Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine das
hat der Bundeskanzler heute angekündigt
nachdem er vorher wochenlang geschwiegen
hatte manche sagen gezaudert jetzt
erklärt er sich hier im ZDF
[Musik]
was nun Herr Scholz Deutschland liefert
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine und erlaubt
auch anderen Ländern die Weitergabe
damit werden deutsche Leopard 2 aus
deutscher Produktion demnächst im Don
Bass und anderswo in der Ukraine gegen
die russische Armee eingesetzt ist
Deutschland damit Kriegspartei nein in
keinem Fall und darum ging es auch zu
keiner Zeit sondern wir haben eine sehr
klare Linie verfolgt in den vielen
Monaten seitdem der furchtbare Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine begonnen
hatte wir haben sehr sehr viele Waffen
geliefert auch sehr wirksame
mittlerweile sind wir in Europa zusammen
mit Großbritannien diejenigen die das
meiste liefern und das wird sich noch
weiter fortsetzen wir sind da vorne dran
und wir haben wenn ich das sagen darf
bei all den Entscheidungen immer darauf
geachtet dass es vollbreitete
Entscheidung sind wohl abgewogene und
das ist Entscheidung sind die wir mit
unseren Verbündeten gemeinsamen in enger
Kooperation treffen so ist es auch hier
was hat Sie dabei besonders geleitet
dass es die Frage da wollen wir etwas
hinterher gehen weil das ist ein
bisschen aus dem Augen verloren worden
was war ihre größte Sorge in den letzten
Wochen das Deutschland allein oder
exponiert ins Visier der Russen ins
Visier von Putin geraten könnte wenn es
Ihnen nicht gelingt die Amerikaner zumal
die Amerikaner im Gleichschritt zu
halten weil das die größte Sorge und ist
diese Gefahr überhaupt gebannt wir haben
immer dafür Sorge getragen ich habe
immer dafür Sorge getragen dass wir im
gleichschutz gewissermaßen handeln das
war so als wir entschieden hatten dass
wir Panzerhaubitzen in dieser
furchtbaren Krieg zur Verfügung stellen
das war so als wir entschieden hatten
dass wir eine sehr wirksame Waffe
mehrfach Raketenwerfer zur Verfügung
stellen die Entscheidung dass wir mit
Luftverteilung wie ihres Tee arbeiten
ist in enger Kooperation mit anderen
gefallen wir haben entschieden dass wir
helfen mit Schützenpanzern auch das
zusammen mit den USA die den Bradley
liefern wie wir den Marder und so ist es
jetzt auch andere machen das mit uns
gemeinsam das ist ein Zeichen der
Kooperation und der Solidarität aber
auch eine ganz klare Botschaft an Putin
das sein imperialistischer Krieg keinen
Erfolg haben wird weil wir die Ukraine
gemeinsam ohne uns trennen zu lassen
unterstützen werden und gleichzeitig
immer darauf achten dass wir nicht
Kriegspartei werden es darf keinen Krieg
zwischen Russland und der NATO geben
nochmal aber warum war es ihnen so
wichtig den Schulterschluss mit den USA
zu suchen wäre nicht auch ein
europäisches Bündnis mit Deutschland
Polen Finnland den Niederlanden und
Großbritannien das wäre doch auch kein
Alleingang gewesen fast möchte ich sagen
das erklärt sich wohl von selbst wir
sind auch eng verbunden in der NATO die
USA und Deutschland sind auch was ganz
konkrete Fragen betrifft der
Verteidigung hier in Deutschland
miteinander verbunden rammstein ist ja
nicht nur ein Ort von dem es von
Verteidigungsministern gibt sondern das
auch für die internationale Strategie
der Vereinigten Staaten eine große Rolle
spielt und so ist es jetzt hier eben
auch ich glaube dass es und ich sage das
ganz klar und ganz scharf
unverantwortlich wäre anders zu handeln
und deshalb habe ich mich auch niemals
von irgendwem treiben lassen und
beeindrucken lassen als all die lauten
Rufe feuchten habe ich gedacht das kann
man verantwortlich nicht machen jeden
Abend schon viele Bürger und Bürger
Fernsehen und hoffen dass die Regierung
und dass der Kanzler die Nerven behält
und den kann ich versichern das war so
und das wird auch so bleiben wir werden
nicht etwas alleine machen sondern immer
nur mit unseren wichtigsten Verbündeten
und selbstverständlich auch mit unserem
wichtigsten Verbündeten zusammen fast
möchte ich sagen das erklärt sich nicht
von selbst warum haben sie diese
Strategie die sie jetzt so plausibel im
Nachhinein darlegen warum haben sie die
nicht zwischendrin den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und uns allen erklärt und
man kann das auch ganz einfach Ermessen
ich habe es ja eben schon wieder gesagt
bei all den Entscheidungen die wir
getroffen haben war das immer so und
könnte daraus auch eine Serie machen wir
sind davon nie abgewichen und ich glaube
dass wenn man das anders machte dass wir
gefährlich wäre dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dann große Sorgen hätten
vor denjenigen die das Land regieren
aber so glaube ich gelingt es auch dass
diejenigen die skeptisch sind die sagen
das ist vielleicht ein Schritt zu weit
sich sicher sind dass die Regierung das
gut abgewogen hat und dass wir bei all
dem was wir tun zur Unterstützung der
Ukraine die Sicherheit Europas und auch
Deutschland nicht aus dem Auge verliert
sagen sie haben sich nicht treiben
lassen ihre Strategie ist aufgegangen
dass er kennen ja heute auch manche an
aber der Eindruck war ein bisschen ein
anderer war nicht am Ende der Preis doch
sehr hoch den sie in den letzten Wochen
jetzt gezahlt haben die beiden fragten
schon nach der Führungsrolle die Polen
waren ungeduldig und sagten wir warten
jetzt gar nicht mehr auf die
Entscheidung von Scholz ist der
Vertrauensverlust nicht am Ende doch
größer und nachhaltiger als sie es jetzt
wahr haben wollen den gibt es auch nicht
das will ich ausdrücklich dazu sagen
alle wissen dass wir den größten Beitrag
leisten auch im Vergleich zu vielen
anderen was jetzt die Unterstützung der
Ukraine betrifft nicht nicht nur
finanziell und humanitär sondern eben
auch wenn es um Waffen die Form gibt
aber alle wissen auch dass wir das nicht
tun als jemand der alleine geht sondern
zusammen mit allen anderen und das ist
ein klares Prinzip nur Theater ich
glaube dass man sich sehr klar machen
muss dass es ja viele Verbündete von
Deutschland in Europa und im
transatlantischen Bündnis in den G7 in
der ganzen Welt gibt und die verstehen
das alle sehr sehr gut und es wäre auch
gar nicht möglich immer wieder solche
gemeinsamen koordinierten
Vorgehensweisen zu entwickeln wenn das
nicht das Prinzip der Zusammenarbeit mit
anderen wäre ich will sehr klar sagen
dass aus meiner Sicht die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger wissen wollen ob sie sich auf
diejenigen die regieren verlassen können
ob die Druck standhalten der Panzer
liefert darf das niemals aus
innenpolitischen Motiven tun sondern
weil es richtig ist im Hinblick auf die
Unterstützung in diesem Fall der Ukraine
die angegriffen wird von Russland und
Russland das ganze Land oder ein Teil
des Landes erobern will aber auch in
Hinblick auf die Entscheidung die wir
treffen für unsere eigene Sicherheit und
das gelingt nur wenn man da starke
Nerven hat und sicher weiß dass man das
mit anderen zusammen voranbringen muss
trotzdem führen viele Verbündete das
Wort scholzing im Munde das hat sich ein
britischer Historiker ausgedacht und das
bedeutet so viel wie Unterstützung
versprechen und sie dann aber doch
verzögern über die 40 zugesagten
marderschützenpanzer darüber diskutiert
Deutschland seit dem letzten Sommer
geliefert sind sie immer noch nicht
warum glauben Sie dass es bei den
Leopard-Panzern jetzt besser klappen
wird erstmal ist das so was wir gemacht
haben das meiste meine sie können ja
gern sich mal umgucken und sie haben das
sicherlich auch mal dokumentiert vor der
ganzen auch bei der ganzen Aufregung
über alles das was du diskutiert worden
ist das dem ein oder der anderen mal aus
dem Blick geraten aber ich wiederhole es
deshalb ja noch mal deutschland ist das
Land das vorne ansteht dass die
Unterstützung betrifft und zwar auch in
den real-lieferungen deshalb ist das ja
auch nicht so utopisch deshalb ist es
umso erstaunlicher dass sie sozusagen
zulassen dass ein anderer Eindruck
entsteht in der Tat das verstecken sich
ja auch manche ein bisschen in der
Kulisse und sagen lassen wir da mal
gestatten Sie mir das auch im Hinblick
auf die Bürger und Bürger die das ja
sehr interessiert es gibt doch gar keine
andere Vorgehensweise die vernünftig ist
dass Leute laut rufen dass sie in ihre
Sendung hier ständig jemand kriegt der
mit ernster Mine sagt sehr sofort und
dies noch und das noch und ich verstehe
das nicht da können Sie jeden Tag 300
von aufbieten und das dann dokumentieren
aber die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen
dass jemand regiert der davon sich nicht
beeindrucken lässt und den Kurs fährt
der für unser Land verantwortlich ist
auch für die Sicherung des Friedens in
Europa und unsere eigenen sich und auch
für unsere eigene Sicherheit und das
heißt dass wir
mit anderen abgestimmt vorgehen und dass
wir es machen und wie gesagt
die Übersetzung von scholzing ist
Deutschland macht das meiste neue
Übersetzung müssen noch mal die
Nachfrage nach den Leopard stellen also
sie versprechen jetzt zwei Bataillonen
das wären ungefähr 90 Stück davon 14
eine Kompanie aus bestimmten der
Bundeswehr die Ukraine sagt aber schon
jetzt sie brauche hunderte Kampfpanzer
um sich gegen eine erwartete
Frühjahrsoffensive der russischen Armee
zu wappnen und möglicherweise auch
durchzusetzen ist nicht schon absehbar
dass das was sie heute verkündet haben
überhaupt nicht ausreicht wir werden ja
mit anderen zusammen Handeln zwei große
Einheiten zusammenstellen in Kooperation
mit vielen europäischen Verbündeten das
war ja auch immer der Wunsch und damit
das klappt werden wir auch viele Dinge
tun die dazu die dringende voraussetzung
sind die Kooperation organisieren dafür
Sorge tragen das ist Munition und Ersatz
Teil Lieferung geben kann dafür Sorge
tragen dass das Training hier in
Deutschland stattfindet und das was wir
jetzt entschieden haben ist das was wir
selber aus unserer eigenen Möglichkeiten
sofort machen können
und wir werden in dieser Linie fortgehen
das ist ganz sicher so aber das wird
schon ein großer Aufwand sein und manche
Länder werden viel Mühe haben ihren
zugesagten Beitrag für diese gemeinsame
Anstrengung zu leisten und die brauchen
auch unsere Unterstützung Deutschland
auch Mühe haben das wirklich zu liefern
wir sind ja immer sehr präzise in dem
was wir konkret sagen das haben wir denn
vorher geprüft können Herr Bundeskanzler
die Leopard 2 den Kriegsverlauf
maßgeblich beeinflussen also sind die
sowas wie ein Game changer
das ist ein furchtbarer Krieg der ja mit
unglaublichen Verlusten einhergeht bei
den Bürgern und Bürgern der Ukraine wo
unzählige gestorben sind in diesem Krieg
im Hinblick auf die Energieversorgung
des Landes wenn wir die Städte und
Dörfer die Infrastrukturen sehen die
zerstört worden sind es sind auch
unglaublich viele Soldaten der Ukraine
gestorben oder verwundet noch viel mehr
so weit wir das beurteilen können
russische Soldaten es ist also ein
furchtbarer sinnloser Krieg für ein
imperialistisches Ziel dass der den
russische Präsident verfolgt der will
ganz einfach etwas was es nach unserer
Vorstellung in Europa nicht mehr hätte
geben sollen nämlich mit macht sich das
Territorium eines anderen Landes
aneignen und wir waren doch schon mal
einig auch als Ergebnis der
Entspannungspolitik die Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt auf den Weg gebracht
hatten dass man mit Gewalt keine Grenzen
in Europa mehr verschiebt deshalb muss
er gestoppt werden können die das war
die Frage diese Kampfpanzer jetzt hat
tatsächlich eine maßgebliche Änderung
herbeiführen damit sie sind sehr wirksam
und sie werden deshalb auch sehr
hilfreich sein
wir wissen dass der russische Präsident
unglaubliche Verluste an eigenen
Soldaten an Material akzeptiert für
diese
unakzeptable Zielsetzung sich einfach
irgendwelches Land unter den Nagel zu
reißen und deshalb muss man davon
ausgehen dass der Krieg auch leider
nicht schnell zu Ende gehen wird aber
die Botschaft die mit dem was wir die
ganze Zeit getan haben in den letzten
Monaten und jetzt auch wieder tun
sorgfältig abgewogen sorgfältig
abgestimmt ist das Putin nicht darauf
rechnen kann dass die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine nachlässt und dass wir er
auch das an wirksam und notwendigen
Mitteln zur Verfügung stellen werden was
sie braucht um sich verteidigen zu
können es geht um Verteidigung und
mancher sorgt sich ja schon dass man in
eine gewisse kriegsdynamik kommt also
jetzt Kampfpanzer
sind das nächste Flugzeuge Truppen sie
haben das heute im Bundestag schon
deutlich
zurückgewiesen versprechen sie den
deutschen damit mit diesen Leopards ist
jetzt auch eine Grenze erreicht die wir
nicht überschreiten ich bin sehr klar im
Bundestag gewesen aber war es schon zu
Beginn des Krieges übrigens auch
zusammen mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten wir haben uns beide sehr
klar geäußert als eine übrigens wenn Sie
sich erinnern ähnlich aufgeregte Debatte
ähnlich vielen Wortmeldungen stattfand
über
Flugverbotszonen über der Ukraine dass
wir das in keinem Fall machen werden
weil das dazu führt dass es eine direkte
Kriegsbeteiligung der Staaten Europas
und der NATO geben würde und deshalb
sind auch Bodentruppen ausgeschlossen
das ist völlig klar ich werde alles
dafür tun dass dieser Krieg nicht zu
einem Krieg zwischen Russland und der
NATO eskaliert genau über diese Frage
der sich immer steigernden
Waffenlieferung ist auch ein Streit in
ihrer eigenen Koalition entbrannt da hat
die
fdp-verteidigungsexpertin Strack
Zimmermann ihrer Regierung und
persönlich Versagen vorgeworfen
SPD-Fraktionschef Mützenich hingegen hat
ihr Schnappatmung bescheinigt und gesagt
sie betreibe Kriegstreiberei war ihnen
das Recht
ich bin überzeugt von der Politik die
ich und meine Regierung verfolgen und
vielleicht hat der heutige Tag ja auch
dazu beigetragen dass einige sich in der
Zukunft etwas besinnen was sie sagen
klar ist die Presseerklärung die man
zuletzt gemacht hat und die nächste
Presseerklärung ist nicht der Maßstab
für internationale Politik die Agenda in
anderen Hauptstädten richtet sich auch
nicht daran wann jemand mal wieder im
Fernsehen auftreten will und deshalb bin
ich ganz sicher dass das auch ein Ende
finden wird ich hoffe es jedenfalls und
sie haben könnte
sich sehr klar und wie ich finde auch
sehr solidarisiert
und sie haben schon registriert dass der
FDP-Vorsitzende Christian Lindner seine
Kollegin aus der Fraktion hat laufen
lassen und nicht interveniert hat
die Regierung ist sich völlig einig in
dem Vorgehen und das gilt für den
Finanzminister genauso um es vorweg zu
sagen wie für den Wirtschaftsminister
den schwersten Job in ihrem Kabinett hat
vermutlich Boris Pistorius jetzt ihr
neuer Verteidigungsminister der ja auch
die 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen jetzt
auf die Strecke auf die Bahn bringen
muss und das ist schwierig genug sie
haben das vor einem Jahr in ihrer Zeiten
wenn Rede angekündigt sogar aus ihrer
eigenen Partei kommen jetzt Stimmen die
sagen das erste Jahr ist eigentlich
ziemlich verloren
bei der Umsetzung dieses und Einsetzung
dieses Sondervermögens
die Frage ist im Grunde wann kommt die
Zeitenwende für die Bundeswehr in
Zeitenwende ist ja der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine so habe
ich das bezeichnet weil damit das
Prinzip das nicht mit gewaltgrenzen
verschoben werden in Europa aufgekündigt
worden ist und darauf reagieren wir zum
Beispiel indem wir sagen wie das in dem
errichtungsgesetz für das Sondervermögen
heißt dass wir im Mittel der Jahre zwei
Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
Verteidigung aufwenden wollen und auch
dadurch dass wir das Sondervermögen
haben das Sondervermögen hilft uns bei
einem fahrtwechsel und es hilft uns auch
zu vermeiden dass wir jetzt Unsinn
machen denn wenn wir entscheiden wie das
jetzt zum Beispiel im Zusammenhang mit
der nuklearen Teilhabe bei der
Bestellung der 35 passiert ist dass wir
das machen wollen dann sind die ja noch
nicht da ich habe das Gefühl bei manchen
Diskussionen hat der eine oder die
andere Vorstellung da gibt's so ein
Regal wo man das alles kaufen kann so
ähnlich wie wenn man Auto kaufen will da
gibt es manchmal auch Wartezeiten aber
die sind ja doch im Verhältnis dazu
überschaubar in vielen
Fällen müssen die Produktion neu
etabliert werden müssen dann auch
konstant aufgebaut werden und wir müssen
diesen Farbwechsel auch benutzen für
Fehlerkorrektur
Fehlercode zu korrigieren die das
erlaube ich mir dann doch etwas
einseitig klar zu sagen die
cdu/csu-verteidigungsminister der
letzten Jahre zu verantworten haben dass
wir für die meisten Waffen nicht
genügend Ersatzteile haben das nicht
genügend Munition bestellt wurde ist das
ist nicht im Zusammenspiel mit der
Industrie eine konstante Produktion gibt
bei manchen Waffen die wir jetzt
geliefert haben und wo wir jetzt noch
gerne zusätzliche Munition haben möchten
muss erst die munitionsproduktion wieder
neu aufgebaut werden sowas sollte uns in
der Zukunft nicht passieren und da
müssen jetzt geordnete Entscheidung
getroffen werden und die sind auch alle
unterwegs und diese geordnete
Entscheidung werden dann die nächsten
Jahre dazu führen dass wir die
Bundeswehr so ausrüsten dass sie zur
Landesverteidigung fähig ist aber genau
das meint der Vorsitzende des
Bundeswehrverbandes André Wüstner an und
geht noch weiter er sagt nämlich Zitat
es müsste eine Kriegswirtschaft geben
weil sich die was wir und damit auch die
Industrie auf einen langen Krieg
einstellen müsse und schon jetzt sei die
Bundeswehr blank sein Vorwurf ist sie
hätten die zeitenwände zwar proklamiert
aber nicht verstanden
ich glaube wir haben alles das ganz gut
verstanden und insgesamt auch
insbesondere gut verstanden dass das ein
sehr langfristiges Projekt ist das kein
Aufschub tutuldet aber wo wir immer
wissen müssen wenn man jetzt bestimmte
Waffen bestellt die entwickelt sind wo
man größere Produktionen haben werden
dann werden die Produktionslinien
aufgebaut dann wird die Lieferung
zustande gebracht und das muss dann in
einer Weise geschehen die eben anders
ist als in der Vergangenheit damit wir
auch nicht in diese Situation kommen
dass wir etwas gerne haben wollen und
uns jemand mitteilt das dauert jetzt
zwei drei oder vier Jahre oder 12 Monate
was weiß ich auch immer das wollen wir
ändern aber das ist eben jetzt mit dem
Sondervermögen möglich weil wir jetzt
systematisch die Dinge auf einen neuen
richtigen Pfad setzen können Herr
Bundeskanzler zu unserer Sendung gehört
die Satz Ergänzung sie kennen das wir
geben ein Halbsatz vor und sie ergänzen
bitte möglichst kurz und spontan der
erste Halbsatz lautet der Grund dafür
dass ich an Verteidigungsministerin
Christine Lambrecht so lange fest
gehalten habe war dass sie sich eine
sehr schwierige Aufgabe zugetraut hat
und das auch in vielen Fällen
vorangebracht hat viele viele
Entscheidungen haben zu Verbesserungen
geführt die jahrelang schon für die
Bundeswehr angestanden hätten dass mein
Kabinett entgegen meinem Versprechen
jetzt aus mehr Männern als aus Frauen
besteht das bedrückt mich und wir werden
auch bei der nächsten Gelegenheit dafür
Sorge tragen dass das anders wird das
Selbstkritik nicht zu meinen
hervorstechenden Eigenschaften gehört
stimmt nicht
den französischen Präsidenten Emmanuel
macron beneide ich um
gar nicht sagte ein schönes Land eine
schöne Hauptstadt wir waren jetzt
zusammen in einem Restaurant essen und
schönen Essen und weiß man das war sehr
gemütlich die Entscheidung wer beim
deutsch-französischen Tandem vorne sitzt
und lenken darf
brauchen wir nicht weil wir
zusammenarbeiten und die Koordination
unserer gemeinsam Aktivitäten unsere
Hauptaufgabe ist das meine grünen
Minister Habeck und baerbock im ZDF
Politbarometer Ranking vor mir liegen
ist gar kein Thema für irgendeine
politische Entscheidung wichtig ist dass
die Regierung gute Arbeit macht und
nachdem wir es geschafft haben dass wir
das Land vor einer Wirtschaftskrise
bewahrt haben und dafür gesorgt haben
dass auch keine
energieversorgungskrise in diesem Winter
eingetreten ist und die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger massiv entlastet haben nehmen wir
jetzt das nächste Ziel in den Blick
nämlich Deutschland zu modernisieren
damit wir als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt auch das erste
CO2-neutrale Industrie Land der Welt
werden der längste Halbsatz dieser
Sendung wenn ich feministische
Außenpolitik in einem Satz erklären
müsste die Hälfte der Menschheit braucht
eine ganz klare Betrachtung und
Unterstützung
dass ich mehr kriegskanzler als
klimakanzler bin
stimmt für den Augenblick weil das im
Vordergrund steht aber wir haben das
Klima und die Frage wie wir den
Klimawandel aufhalten nicht vergessen
schon im letzten Jahr sind weitreichende
Entscheidungen getroffen worden zum
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energie der Wind
Energie der Solarenergie des Stromnetzes
wir werden viele viele Prozesse zur
Modernisierung unserer Infrastruktur
beschleunigen dazu sind jetzt aktuell
weitere Vorhaben im Bundestag angelande
zum Beispiel die Veränderung des
verwaltungsrechtsordnung und wir machen
da weiter Herr Bundeskanzleramt
gleichwohl hatten sie sich natürlich
ihre Regierungszeit etwas anders
vorgestellt dann kam der Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine im Februar
jährlich das die Zivilbevölkerung sie
haben darauf hingewiesen ist brutalste
Aggression ausgesetzt wir sehen die
Bilder tagtäglich wenn wir vielleicht
etwas größer mal schauen auf dieses auf
nächstes Jahr was ist ihre Perspektive
wie das fragen sich glaube ich alle kann
dieser Krieg beendet werden
der Krieg kann beendet werden wenn der
russische Präsident und Russland
versteht dass der das Ziel nicht zu
erreichen ist mit immer mehr Gewalt sich
an Teil des Territoriums der Ukraine
anzueignen und Truppen zurückzieht damit
es zu einer Verständigung und einem
fairen Frieden zwischen beiden Ländern
kommen kann die Ukraine ist dazu bereit
aber wird es für den Beginn von
Friedensverhandlungen nicht eher
notwendig sein noch mehr Waffen zu
liefern aus der amerikanischen Regierung
ist jetzt zu hören dass sie davon
ausgeht dass Putin erst verhandeln würde
wenn er Sorge haben muss dass seine
Herrschaft über die Krim bedroht ist
teilen Sie diese Analyse es gibt ganz
viele Erwägungen aber das eigentliche
ist ja dass wir uns ganz sicher sein
können über die Motivation und die Pläne
von Putin weil er das alles öffentlich
gesagt hat schon lange vor dem Krieg
aber auch unmittelbar davor als ich
Oskar mit ihm vier Stunden an diesem
langen Tisch saß hatte auch lange
erläutert warum eigentlich diese Länder
Teil Russlands sein und warum das aus
der Geschichte sich begründet und aus
sprachlichen Traditionen alles falsch
und es ist ja sowieso einen anderen
Kommunismus man weiß dass der
ukrainische Präsident unter den
Ukrainern ein russisch Sprecher gewesen
ist und wie viele andere auch aber die
ganze Nation ist jetzt geeint im Kampf
für die Verteidigung der eigenen
Integrität und Souveränität Vladimir
Putin in ihren Überlegungen wenn sie
jetzt daran denken wie sieht irgendwann
das Verhältnis dass man zu Russland
wieder aufbaut aus noch irgendeine Rolle
bei Russland regiert entscheiden die
Russinnen und Russen das muss immer für
uns ganz klar sein es gehört zwar zu den
eigenwilligen Ängsten russischer
Regierung das von außen versucht würde
die
Entscheidungsstrukturen des Landes zu
beeinflussen das ist aber blanker Unsinn
uns geht es darum dass ein so großes
Land das ja
im größten Teil des europäischen
Kontinents als Fläche hat das ein so
großes Land friedlich mit uns
zusammenlebt und deshalb ist dieser
Krieg ja so furchtbar ich sage das noch
mal Helmut Schmidt und Willy Brand haben
gekämpft dafür dass es Verständigung
gibt die KSZE die
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
waren große Verständigung die aus dieser
Zeit stammen und bei den ging es eben
darum festzulegen dass man nicht mit
Gewalt Grenzen verschiebt
zum Schluss Herr Bundeskanzler wünschen
Sie sich dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt ihre Parteivorsitzende Saskia
esken hat diese Frage neulich ganz klar
mit ja beantwortet sie konnten sich
bisher noch nicht zu mit dieser Klarheit
dazu durchringen deshalb noch mal die
Frage muss die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnen darf den Krieg nicht verlieren
das ist für mich völlig klar und deshalb
unterstützen wir sie so umfangreich und
das was das bedeutet ist ja auch klar zu
beschreiben es geht darum dass sie die
Integrität und Souveränität des eigenen
Landes verteidigen kann und das ist wenn
man weiß wie brutal die Aggression
Russlands vorgetragen worden ist ein
sehr weitreichendes Ziel das heißt Herr
Bundeskanzler Russland muss den Krieg
verlieren
Russland darf mit seinen Zielen nicht
durchkommen und das muss sagen muss
scheitern mit dem was es sich
vorgenommen hat nämlich sich die Ukraine
untertan zu machen
das war unser was nun vielen Dank Herr
Bundeskanzler vielen Dank auch für ihr
Interesse hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Matthias vorner und einem ZDF Spezial
und auch mit Reaktionen auf dieses
Interview